in the First Act of Megan Gemma
introduces KD to her very first robotic
design Bruce even going so far as to
point out whether CPU was located any
astute viewer could assume it would come
back later in the film it's a Trope but
not all tropes are bad still it would
have made it much easier for Katie to
power down her murderous doll before
disassembling her why didn't she the
short answer is likely the one already
alluded to that's such an anti-climactic
ending would be a huge letdown to say
the least the longer answer is an
attempt to ship Megan down was made
earlier in the house by Gemma not only
did she get smacked and throttled for
her efforts but Megan also told her she
was no longer following her protocols in
a real-world situation Katie would
probably be unaware of this prior
interaction having neither seen nor
overheard it and likely would have made
her own attempt to shut off the doll
however in a suspension of disbelief
required a single scene has to suffice